Okay. So welcome back to the Cloud Native
Compass. I'm your host, David Flanagan. And today,
I am joined by Nathan from Wix Engineering
as we discuss and share wonderful insights into
the world of event driven architectures.
Hello, Nathan. How are you today?
Hi, David. It's a pleasure to be here.
Well, thank you so much for joining me.
I'm really excited for this episode.
Event driven architectures are are just what keep
me excited about technology
even after twenty years and been able to
dig into it with experts and understand how
they approach complex domains via event driven architectures
is always the highlight of my week. So
thank you so much for joining me.
I discovered
you via the Wix engineering blog, which turned
out to be a bit of a gold
mine for engineering content. So before we dive
into that and event driven architectures,
could you share a little bit more about
you?
Sure.
So
I've been a software engineer now for close
to twenty years, I think. And it's
been such a lovely experience for me. So
for the last eight years, I've been in
Wix, which really drove me to become much
better engineer in all of the skill sets
that engineer should have. And also be able
to share it and want to share what
I've learned and and what
Wix has achieved with the rest of the
world. And I think it's really important, and
I encourage every
engineer, no matter what is their skill level,
to do the same and and try to
write a blog post about their experiences and
what they learned. There's no such thing as
something that is not interesting or something that
no one will care about. And even if
you if you don't get a lot of
exposure, it's still great to to create content.
It it it gets you a create in
a creative high, so I really recommend it.
Yeah. That's great advice so early on in
the episode. Like, I I often refer to
this as, a collective knowledge when I speak
at conferences and such as, like, the more
we can get engineers
working on their own their own issues, right,
that their organization has, that their team has,
that they personally have. And the more we
share this knowledge in a public forum, the
more that other people can learn and build
upon that knowledge. Right? It provides foundations for
people to go and do wonderful things with
technology. So that's such great advice. Thank you
for sharing that. So you've you've been at
WEX and you're saying that it's kind of,
you know, improved
your engineering chops. You're working on fun problems.
I mean, just to give people some context
and clarity on what Wix does and what
kind of scale they're operating at,
can you just share a bit more details
there? Sure. So
Wix has a very powerful website building platform.
And over the years, it has enabled,
all kinds of people with, different skill set
levels, to build websites. We were pioneers in
building websites based on AI, for instance,
even before it became so trendy and viral,
like these days. And in more recent years,
we expanded our reach, from, like, self creators
to agencies
and
web professionals
and created a whole ecosystem platform.
So we don't only manage
online presence, but also manage businesses online
from stuff like building and managing your bookings
and schedule for your yoga and Pilates studio
to,
sophisticated tools like third party drop shipping. And
as all as we expanded our offerings,
more and more customers
were brought in and the scale has really
increased. So we have around 2,500
microservices in production, even more added every week.
And they come up with a lot of
visitors, around 1,000,000,000 unique visitors every month,
which gives
more than 500,000,000,000
HTTP requests per day and 70,000,000,000
Kafka events produced every day. So very large
scale and a very big distributed system where
there are a lot of challenges to keep
up the high availability,
performance, low latency,
and resiliency in the fault tolerance.
Wow. I mean, I I was asking to
give the audience clarity on scale, and I
think you've just surpassed the numbers I even
had in my head. So those are some
pretty chunky numbers you've got running through your
system. So let's gonna touch on something there.
Right? Said you've got 2,500 microservices.
It's growing every week. Did Wix start off
as a monolithic application,
or has it always been a microservice architecture
or service oriented architecture to some degree? And
were you part of that migration, if so?
Yeah. I think
very early on,
Wix adopted the service oriented architecture. I think
there were monoliths.
Like, at the very beginning, I think, there
were services that were expanded into a monolith
and were written, like, I think back in,
like, twenty o six, '20 o '7, '20
o '8. It's before my time, but with,
like,
Java technologies,
like, enterprise technologies,
monolithic stuff. But very, very quickly after that,
especially since we adopted Scala, we went over
to look more smaller and smaller services
and microservices
and haven't looked back since, really. We kept
on improving standardization,
ease of building in a new service with
all the different
cross cutting concerns
that are involved because it's really a big
challenge. So, like, keeping Velocity
fast with all the needed building blocks for
every service because while we may not be
monolithic,
it's in some respects, can think about the
Wix platform as a distributed monolith, right, because
you
have all these verticals
that offer a lot of more extra features
for the different kinds of websites. So you
can have an ecommerce store, but you can
also have the bookings features or a restaurant
or a hotel, etcetera.
And all of these have to work together
along with the
site editing infrastructure,
etcetera. So we have a lot of of
of different services working on very different domains.
But at the end of the day,
they need to have basic language to to
communicate, to propagate
user context,
and to do regulation like GDPR
and a lot of other concerns. Of course,
concerns where you work with microservices,
it's much harder to debug, much harder to
know what's going on. So you wanna have
good monitoring infrastructure
in place and and ease
of, like, a lot of tools to investigate.
So all of that has to be built
in to each and every microservice. And that's
why I say, okay. They are created independently
by different teams,
and they have completely different
domains, business domains. But in the technical aspect,
you can think about them as a distributed
model.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you. Like, if those you
know, you're an you're an engineer. Right? Your
nine to five is to to write code
and help build out the Wix platform. How
many of those services
do you have in your head as a
2,500?
I know it's a completely superficial question, but
I'm just curious, like, what is your exposure
to application
that size? How much of it can you
actually grow up on your own? Right. So
as an infrastructure
developer,
I I'm exposed to potentially all of them.
Like, each day,
some some team from another part of Wix
will contact us about some question or issue.
So at times, I'm familiar more with with
with with parts different parts.
But, of course, it's really impossible
to keep all 2,500,
in your head. So I know, the different
verticals. I know the different challenges.
Like, some verticals have more throughput than others.
You know, as the funnel shrinks,
you get less,
like, technical challenges. You can still have a
lot of API and and business and and,
like, business logic challenges, but you'll have less
technical challenges. So I'm probably more familiar with
the higher scale ones,
I would say.
But getting 2,500 is impossible for sure. Yeah.
I mean,
I I don't know what the split is
between application services and infrastructure services, but I
imagine there's a lot of identity stuff going
on. There's a lot of caching going on.
There's the message processing. There's consumers. Like, you
know, when you have as and I'm making
some assumptions right now. Right? Because I I
don't know a lot about works yet. But
I imagine there's a substantial amount of platforming
that has to be done to support the
developers to be able to, you know, onboard
and run their services
when you get to this level of scale.
So well, in fact, let's before I say,
like, what are the challenges, let's just start
off with, like, you know, why go down
this path of event driven architectures for a
system like like Wix? Like, what are the
pros and and what are the cons of
this? Sure. So
usually, when you start off with microservices,
if you come from analysts,
then you're used to function calls. Right? And
procedure calls.
And then the natural extension of that when
you split up to multiple services is to
do remote procedure calls or something
similar like
REST APIs.
And that's very a very natural thing to
do. Now what I've noticed that can happen
in such situations is it's it can be
a bit restrictive.
For instance,
you want to call call a service.
And actually, what like, in ecommerce,
your
card service calls the catalog service and
the inventory service, etcetera. And what usually happens
is, like, a big chain of of of
calls that that occur
in in such situations. Right? Like, you mentioned
identity
probably will be in the context, but also
a lot of of of business procedures
happen on different services, and and and you
start getting a very large
chain of of, requests between these services. And
and this this can really form a a
big challenge where you need to take care
of making sure that you still have resiliency
and fault tolerance in place. And that can
be tricky because you have to make sure
that you meet deadlines and give out responses
back in in in a orderly amount of
time, like a normal amount of time. And
when you spread out the request and and
get, like, a Russian dollar of requests here,
you you you end up being really dependent
on the availability
and the performance on each and every one
of these services along the chain. So it
can really make your
your request brittle. So, of course, there are
mitigations to stuff like that. Right? You can
if if a service is not, responding and
failing, you can retry.
Or
if, some service is completely down, you want
to avoid cascading failure, so, you introduce circuit
breakers to reduce the impact and not affect
the entire, system. But while we do have
a lot of
cloud applications at Wix with a lot of
request responses,
At the same time, we really rely very
heavily on an event driven architecture
as well. So it's kind of a hybrid
architecture.
And this type of architecture really makes everything
a lot more resilient,
and I would also say
decoupled.
So if we have some event happening on
the site infrastructure level. Right? So all of
these verticals
are interested in that. So imagine
all of them now calling the site's infrastructure
and requesting all kind of information.
So that can really get a a really
big bottleneck and really slow things down. So
you can cache a lot of the responses,
but caching is a mechanism that's really need
to be deployed carefully. You want to avoid
stale values because stale values can really corrupt
your data and provide the incorrect answers.
So if you have just events
being emitted
from the site infra service, so all the
verticals, different verticals like e comm and restaurants
and hotels can can consume them and and
decide what's interesting to them and keep that
smaller dataset
on their side, you get a much more
resilient
distributor system here. You get a lot more
like, the the decoupled nature
means that you reduce blast radiuses.
You you kind of silo issues. Right? If
if the restaurant's
consumer of site events has some issue now,
it does it can it just cannot affect
any other vertical.
It's impossible. Right? So that's a lot a
great advantage.
And I'm sorry for the long answer, but
also
Wix,
like I said, evolved from only catering to
do it yourself,
site owners to actually work with developers.
And then they also require to know sometimes
what's going on, in the site. And one
of the ways like, if they develop JavaScript
on top of a Wix site, they wanna
get sometimes JavaScript callbacks and do actions when
stuff happen.
So,
naturally, it will be much easier to expose
all the rich possibilities
that the Wix platform offers as JavaScript events
or callbacks
than you would want to have the ability
to emit events from all of your microservices
potentially, right, to make it a platformized effort
so that it easily
then translated over
to to this JavaScript callback or to the
to an HTTP webhook and stuff like that.
So it gives you flexibility,
resilience,
and the ability
to layer stuff one on top of the
other much more easily in in a more
robust way.
Okay. Thank you. So just to kinda recap
a little bit of that. Right? You know,
you're talking about how you've got services,
and and some of them have, let's call
it, an an an appetite for eventual consistency
to the point, I guess, it's maybe not
binary, but either they cannot accept eventual consistency,
and those are probably gonna be more likely
to be your your current based endpoints that
you were mentioning. And then there's the ones
where it's okay. Maybe we can accept some
eventual consistency so they may take on a
more event driven pattern.
And you also spoke there about cascading failures
and, you know, the Russian doll of HTTP
request, right, which is
a a very difficult
problem.
You know, I think the paper that I
often refer to here is the Twitter paper
on where they were trying to solve something
like this with retry logic, baking it in
to, like, a client library, which is now
spun out to service mesh.
Is that the approach that Wix take?
Do you use service mesh to provide that
tooling to your application developers, or have you
gone down a definite route to kinda help
them with retries and circuit breakers? Like, I'd
really love to understand how you've implemented that.
Sure. So, yes, we we do utilize
a service mesh,
and
we
I don't think there's a standard
circuit breaker mechanism at Wix. And I think
we try at the end of the day
the
responsibility of the specific
service,
like, as a client. I think service mesh,
in our case, mostly helps with easy, like,
discoverability and easily addressing,
right, the the correct service and and not
need needing to worry about it the request
getting to to the correct correct place.
And so in that respect,
what what we do try to enforce
in these requests usually like, the default time
that a request
has to get a response is quite short.
I don't remember the exact amount of seconds,
but it's it's quite short.
So you have to have a good reason
to to then increase it. Right? Because the
longer
the response
can potentially be allowed to return,
the more problematic
it is for the health of the distributor
system. Right?
So the time budgets here are are quite
constrained. And
if a service does not meet up to
those standards, then they need to work hard
on the performance,
right, improve their RPC endpoints.
And if their database
is starting to have to act act up,
then they need to
investigate how how to solve it and maybe
switch to a different technology
and stuff like that. But I would say
that for Wix, a lot of the services
don't suffer
necessarily the scaling issues because of the funnel
I talked about. So we have, like, the
heavy duty services that have very specialized
data storage solutions,
and others usually are are quite fine with
MySQL.
So
will get MySQL in the last few years
introduced document database.
So because we were heavily invested in MySQL,
we took the ability to now work with
documents and JSONs with MySQL in both hands,
and we have database layer on top of
that.
So it it's really simple and fast to
to create new
domain entities and and to persist them and
update them. And
in terms of the
latencies
and and performance,
usually, it works quite well quite well, and
and they get their own tables. So sorry
about the rabbit hole,
but
maybe I'm my own Russian doll here. But
in terms of
on on getting the the best performance
and and resilience,
it's up to the developer at the end
of the day. The developer like, if I'm
I'm starting to notice that my KPIs
are starting
to be problematic and it's because of this
this service,
then may I may reach out to them
and ask them to to to fix their
performance
if they haven't noticed it. And another way
I can do it is I can consume
their events
and have my own materialized view and then
and then just
take the responsibility for performance completely
for my for my on my end, which
is,
like you said, if you can do it
in eventually eventually consistent way, then
it's definitely an option. And I think at
weeks, like, 99%
of the cases, eventually consistent is good enough.
Okay.
There was a lot there in that answer.
So let's let's cover a few things and
remove a few assumptions for the audience. Right?
Yeah. When you interview me, you need to
keep a notebook.
Have been taking notes. You'll have heard my
keyboard touch. But
Yeah. You we we both mentioned service mesh.
You confirmed there as some service mesh. We're
using some API surface of that. So I
just wanna clarify.
Does WEX run on top all these 200
2,500
services on top of Kubernetes?
Yes. Right. Okay. Cool. You also spoke Short
answer.
Yeah.
Well, we're gonna get to the harder stuff.
There's what you worry. Plenty of time for
us to chat. But you spoke about the
the application developers and their responsibilities,
you know, where they get to select their
own tooling, their own databases. They were responsible
for client side retries and such.
You're on the back end of our team.
Right? You lead the back end of our
team. So I'd love for us to understand
how the responsibilities
at Wix work with regards to what does
the back end of our team,
provide.
Is it just cluster? Is it SRE semantics?
Is it observability?
Is it guidance? Are you embedded within application
teams? Like, can you go into just how
you work with the the devs and how
you put this all together?
Sure.
So there are two levels of infrastructure
for back end at Wix.
There's the more, I would say, low level
low level part, which says, okay, we're running
Kafka.
How can we translate that to work well
with microservices?
Or, okay, we're running MySQL.
How can we simplify
it for, like, routing
layers on top and make it
easier to work with? And and also caching
and stuff like that. So we we have
a caching
solution that is partially based on AWS
DynamoDB, like the second layer. So I would
say this, like, the more cloud infrastructure
translations to microservices level. And then on top
of that, we have the I would call
them the platform engineers maybe. Their goal is
to make, like, building a microservices super simple
and fast. Okay?
So the journey for the developer usually starts
with writing the
interface in protobuf.
And it's not only the interface of of
the service, like what RPC
and Kafka endpoints are part of it. But,
also, a lot of the tweaks are done
in in in Proto,
and then
code is generated behind the scenes for it
to work.
And then you complete a little bit more
configuration in code, and you can focus on
the business logic. So because you have database
layer that you work with and I'm talking
about, like, the 80%. Right? It's not like
each and every service weeks, especially not the,
like,
really high scale ones. They they can't
operate under these these templates. Right? But for
the 80%, like, we have a lot of
verticals, a lot of various segments that have
a little bit less traffic. And all of
these tools and and this framework,
really allows them to focus on, like, the
domain challenge. Right? How
can we make sure that we provide the
best booking solution and and make it so
you can have all all these cool features
on, like, sending reminders
and
starting soon and and be able to easily
rebook
rebook classes
and maybe suggesting classes that are similar. Right?
So all of these rich business domains,
they can focus on that. And what do
they get behind the scenes? So they get
the auto generated
RPC
endpoints.
So all they need to do is
fill in the what action to take when
when they get such a request and how
to handle and process an incoming event. Right?
They they need to write that in. And
if they need to act interact with the
database, so usually,
they they just work with our
simple DB layer that I mentioned before. It's
the works with document
flavor
of of MySQL
and with JSON support. So what happens?
You get your
RPC or Kafka
domain entity,
And you use another tool that you can
employ here, which is auto mapping to your
data layer entity. Right?
So and that data layer entity,
you can easily add indexes if needed
to get better performance and stuff like that.
So
the idea is to really
abstract away the intricacies
of the
SQL queries or or stuff like that. And
you also will get built in, like, PII
encryption when needed or
the built in
notifications
and segmentation needed for GDPR
and stuff like that. Right?
And now we're getting to the data locality
realm where
because of other regulations, you need to keep
something only in Europe or
only in The US and stuff like that.
So all of that can be taken care
of for you seamlessly.
Yeah. So if I recap,
we we get, like, the platform engineers giving
you really simple interfaces
to auto generate the code. And we're actually
really excited about
the possibilities
of
large language models like Chachi PT to harness
all the great work that's been done so
far and
take it to the next level and increase
velocity even further.
Okay.
Awesome. I always like to just give, like,
that ten second recap to make sure I
even I understand everything, and we haven't messed
up on any of the good details there.
You could pick the low level cloud infrastructure
team, the back end of your team where
you're providing the the Kubernetes clusters, the cloud
resources,
and all that stuff. Right? Yeah. So that's
another part of Wix. Wix is a big
company.
So, like, the cloud infrastructure
is run, like, outside of the back end.
And then
we
like, I'm part of the you can say
CloudInfo
for for the back end.
And, actually, we developed a lot of cool
stuff on top of Kafka. Right? Because
you wanna make sure that you get the
best performance out of Kafka possible.
And
to solve
all these tricky edge cases of, oh, wait.
For some reason,
the service pod wasn't able to reach the
Kafka
broker for some reason, and and we get
we added a resiliency layer here.
And
for the consumer side, we added resiliency
because we implemented all kinds of reach wise
strategies
built in. It's really easy to configure.
And so we have a rich set of,
like, event driven messaging infrastructure
on top of
of Kafka.
And we also have
self-service tools to manage issues in your production
environment. So things like
easily pinpointing
an event that that you're
interested in in our control plane that we
built or
investigating
why some partitions in Kafka have
a consumer lag on them
and saying what what events potentially
got stuck in the processing
and
also
be able to skip or replay events. So
you can see that it's a bit more
like
infrastructure y and production y on that level.
And the top level on top of that
is,
like, having the frameworks in place
to, like, write a microservice
skeleton
in a few minutes and focus on the
business logic.
Okay. Great overview there. So I think we've
covered a lot of, like, the the back
end platform engineering, providing tooling.
We've got the application developers over here. They
only really need to focus on their business
logic.
You know, especially
and I wanna kinda look back into event
driven architectures. Right? So we got all these
application developers. And I don't I don't know
how many application developers you've got. Right? But
I'm gonna take a guess. You've got two
and a half thousand services.
Let's assume any team is responsible for, say,
10.
That's 250 teams. Let's assume five persons
per team. We're potentially talking about 1,250 developers.
Is that anywhere close? I think
it's
it's it's in the ballpark. Yeah. Okay. Cool.
So, you know, that that's a lot of
people who hopefully focus on on our domain
logic. But, you know, based on the conversation
we've had so far, I'm curious.
We've event driven systems which are notoriously hard.
Right?
They're they've got a service. It's a Madden
event, and they decide, oh, I'm gonna change
the structure of this event. And they're sitting
there going, is this an upcast? I created
a v two. Is this a new event?
Do they get support from, like, the back
end teams, the platform teams, the people with
experience?
Is there like, how do they are they
expected to know all of this, or do
you guide them on this? Do you support
them for that? So I think one of
the subject here is scheme evolution and and
versioning. Right?
So definitely,
we have, like, design guidelines and and
platformization
guidelines on how to make sure that when
you design your microservice,
you write a forward looking API, but also
one that can evolve over time. And
also, you know, because of the power of
protobuf, you can os easily add linters that
make sure that you you don't easily mess
that up so
that you and because of auto generated calls,
it's built in with the slash v one
for the first thing. So it will be
easy to do a v two
and if needed. So we don't really have,
like, automatic
linting
for for the backward forward compatibility
of each of the
domain entities that we send over the events.
But with Portabuff,
you you pretty much know that it will
be ill advised to just go and
and delete
a field. It's better to, like, market a
deprecated and add another field.
And so there are definitely
guidelines on how how to to do these
minor changes to your schema.
And
I think I don't remember. There are some
basic rules that enforce some stuff.
So
but
I can recollect them right now. So some
of this is responsibility
of the developer.
But because
like, part of the onboarding process, Wix, is
is how do you write a product which
is API first. Right? You it used to
be different. It used to be like, okay.
So we have some
UI and some back end service behind it.
And
so the AI is
going to ask all kinds of things, so
we need to build an API for it.
But because
we we've evolved Wix into a platform that
also has develop developers on top of it
and because it's a bigger company now, so
you need developers to communicate,
you don't want, like, Slack or Microsoft Teams
to be
a barrier to understand how to consume something
from some events from another service. Right? So
we want everything to be well documented,
easily discoverable,
and easily
evolved. Right? So so I can safely stay
on the older version for a while, especially
if I'm an external developer. Right?
And and then safely migrate on my own
time to to the new version.
And it will be the responsibility of the
service owner to make sure that both version
versions are are supported.
Okay. And are you leveraging like, just because
you mentioned kinda discoverability there. Right? Are you
leveraging anything, like, Backstage, like an IDP that
aggregates and collects all of these service definitions
and the event definitions and the protobufs and
gives someone a place to go and search
them?
Sure. So,
actually,
because
of,
like, the unique nature of Wix's
platform,
a lot of work has been done to
expose things to external developers,
and we built it by ourselves. So there
was no point in, like, not doing the
same for internal developers.
So there are products out there. Right?
For instance,
especially for events, have the Confluent
schema registry.
And there's also API Courier, I think, or
something like that from Red Hat, like open
source.
And
those are great tools for for managing and
discovering
event schemas.
For specifically for Wix, we built our own
custom
services.
So
each time a new service is within the
its protobuf
has the event definitions,
they are transferred automatically
to the
main repository
that keeps all all of the the definitions.
And
you can also listen if if you're, like,
a CICD service or
some other build related service that cares when
new events are created so that you can
do stuff with them. You can listen to
that
and create all kinds of cool stuff on
top of that.
And, also, I think
for RPC communication,
with the service mesh, it's also important to
know that
a new service has been created or updated,
and so events are emitted on that as
well to allow the
communication
to to be simple there as well.
And
and so because of everything is based on
protobuf, you get the schema.
You get
well documented stuff. And
once you translate it, hopefully, to a strongly
typed language
like Scala or TypeScript, you also get the
type safety
when you consume it
and or or call the RPC endpoint as
well. Awesome.
Let's kinda jump back to something you said
earlier as well. So I I I love
that answer. Right? You're you're saying that you're
a developer company. You've got public facing APIs.
There's a bit of dog fitting. The discoverability
is the same as the people that use
the platform, which is awesome. That's kind of
what I took away from that, so I
hope that's correct. But
he also said earlier that, you know, sometimes
you have to approach an application team because
they may not have noticed that the round
trip time on an API request is, like,
it's growing exponentially. It's getting out of control.
Whatever that regression is, it could be anything.
Right?
I'm assuming they maybe don't
know a lot of the times that they
have dashboards,
metrics, traces, logging. I am assuming these are
potentially provided by, like, the templates you mentioned,
which are provided by the platform team. So
they're just taking this cookie cutter
boilerplate and injecting our domain logic,
maybe not aware of all the stuff that's
going on in the background for them. It
got me kind of thinking.
Like, is Wix a a polyglot organization?
If I was new at Wix, I've got
a service that I wanna write, and there's
no template for, like, Rust or Alexa or
PonyLang. And I'm like, hey. I really wanna
do this in Pony.
Are you gonna just tell me no, or
is there a process there to bring on,
like, new technologies?
Sure. So
every technological stack
has
a new one, has incurred incurred,
like, cost
in an organization,
especially
for like, you have one developer that's super
excited about Elixir,
and then
writes a service in Elixir. But what's what
happens when
they decide to leave the company? Like, who
is going to maintain this Elixir
service?
So so we start off on the JVM,
mostly Scala. And then it was apparent that
because there are a lot of front end
developers writing JavaScript
and
you want them to easily write middleware services
and rendering services,
So relatively quickly,
like, Node. Js
became
an additional first class citizen,
like with Scala.
And in recent years,
they are starting to gain, like, a bigger,
bigger effort
to expand, like, the the offering. So why
not write in Java and Go and Python
as well? Now in order to achieve that,
like I mentioned, a very complex, let's call
it, platform framework
and a lot of stuff.
So it's not and that's on the JVM,
and it's not really so simple to to
achieve that.
So one way that we're experimenting now is
with kind of a sidecar pattern with with
two containers
where we have the
host container,
which is running the JVM,
and all of the cool microservice
infrastructure
that I talked about. Then you have the
guest container that can be a Node. Js
container
or a Python or or a Go container.
And
they communicate via gRPC.
just
so you you specify the proto because proto
can be in any language,
and you can implement your
event handler
or your RPC endpoint in in the languages
I mentioned, and it will
get invoked from the host that will actually
do the heavy lifting. Another
approach we're contemplating
perhaps is use utilizing GraalVM
also
to get that working.
But, like, in terms of
cost benefit analysis, I think, well, definitely,
I don't see, like, the engineering of Wix
going to, hey. Just write in any
code, like, language you ever saw. And because
it's cool
because at the end of the day,
there's this
production system that
needs to be well maintained and and get
good
performance and and keep
our customers happy at the end of the
day. Awesome. Thank you. Okay. So based on
everything you've just said, you know, there's a
lot of JVM happening, and you mentioned Graal
as well. Right? But they're definitely heavy JVM
users. Your event driven architecture
on AWS,
you've got Kafka NMX, which is notoriously difficult
to kind of scale it with resource intensive.
And the costs must be rather astronomical, I
would imagine, for a company of x scale.
You know, you mentioned that wonderful number at
the start of the episode, 70,000,000,000.
I think it was events per day.
So maybe you can dive into that a
little bit more detail and tell us what's
interesting from your perspective. Sure. I would love
to do that.
So,
basically,
over the
the last couple of years, we we're trying
hard to see
how we can
keep the costs down. So I mentioned that
microservices are new microservices spin up every week,
but
we need to see how the infrastructure costs
don't
increase
linearly with that. Right?
So we have our infrastructure
on top of Kafka, for instance. And
we saw that we need to allow to
have a lot more Kafka brokers
because
we have so many microservices,
and all of them need to connect to
the Kafka brokers and
understand,
like, is there something for me to consume
now? Right? Now all not all parts of
all services are gonna get stuff they need
to to consume.
And
but they're going to run,
our infrastructure
and waste CPU memory,
in order to do that.
So
in order to mitigate this, we actually
created
three services
for each of the basic Kafka
features. So we have a Kafka producer, a
Kafka consumer, and a Kafka administrator.
So for each of them, we created a
proxy that
in this way, we can really, really limit
the amount of connections that we need for
for the brokers,
and then we can really limit the amount
of brokers that we actually need to run.
So while the admin proxy and producer proxy
is really straight kind of straightforward to do
because they are stateless,
for the consumer proxy,
it's a real it's been a real adventure
where
you need to
keep,
like, the state of of which consumers
are now, connected
and to shard
the the and load balance,
between
the pods and have
a lot of work
on the stateful nature of consuming from Kafka,
which is really exciting and challenging.
And we're also trying to
reduce
Kafka based
traffic
because that's also quite expensive for us.
So we're considering now that we have our
our service
our proxy service, we're considering
doing
all kinds of
events caching and stuff like that in order
to
if you have a lot of consumers for
the same event,
we can,
reduce the the
the pressure on Kafka and and just sometimes,
get caches from ourselves, so from our proxy
service. So a lot of really challenging technical
stuff
we're we're doing now
in order to reduce our our Kafka bills,
basically. Wow. Okay. So
so the problem statement there, right, is you
have so many consumers and purchasers of Kafka
connecting to all of the Kafka brokers that
you're having to scale out horizontally to the
brokers to handle them and have connections.
So in order to avoid that,
you know, that that's because that's a cost
thing. Right? We we running the JVM on
a container on top of a Kubernetes cluster
is quite a chunky thing to do, and
then you got that across so many services.
Yeah. Okay. I understand the problem statement really
well.
You've went on the solutions approach of you
said you wrote three proxies. Right? But it
sounds like they're slightly more sophisticated than just
a proxy. Like, they're actually their own little
orchestrator
within the cluster.
So all the consumers and producers sorry. I'm
cutting you off here. But all the producers,
the consumers only ever speak to your proxy,
and then it handles some, I guess, like,
delegation of all the Kafka workloads. Yes. So
when you have a lot less producers connecting
to actually, Kafka produces connecting to the Kafka
workers,
that that you don't need the 2,500
services
times
the number of pods they have to connect.
You only you need a much smaller set
of producers to actually do the work for
them, and then you really limit it now
to connection. That's how you save producer connection.
And over on the consumer side,
so, yeah, you you you consume for them,
and then you delegate to them via
RPC, which is much
much less cost intensive
in our data centers.
I hope that clarified it. It does. Yeah.
It's really interesting.
Just
fun problems and fun solutions that you get
to work on.
And, really, I think it's just exciting that
you're able to kind of share that with
the audience. I think they're gonna take a
lot away from that. So thank you for
sharing that with us. Yeah. I enjoy coming
to work every day.
Awesome.
We have gone over time, so thank you
for being patient and answering all these questions.
I'll just I mean, I could easily talk
to you for another hour. I I think
we'll maybe do a part two in a
little while if you're up for it. But
let's finish with something a bit more fun
just to, you know, get us on the
way. But you mentioned a lot of tools
in today's episode. Right? From Kubernetes to Kafka
to MySQL
to the Scala to Graal.
Like, if there were only three tools that
you had that you could pick and everything
else would just be removed from you. Like,
what are the three most important tools to
you and Wix engineering that you just could
not live away? For myself or for Wix
engineering?
Let's do both. Let's start with you.
Okay.
For for myself, I I actually really, enjoy
working with the functional library on top of
Scala called Zio, which I
really enjoy working in every day because it's
really
tuned for
high concurrency
and
asynchronous work and
get all the benefits of functional programming.
So I really enjoy working it every day.
Don't take it away from me.
And
I think Kafka has proven to be very
powerful, versatile.
And and so we solve so much with
it in in Wix. So I definitely
don't see, like, Wix without it.
That's like the two biggest ones for me.
Alright. Awesome.
K. And do you wanna add any more
tools, or do wanna leave it as ZIO
and
Kafka. Right?
I I think
those are the the ones like, if if
you're on the on the JVM or or,
like,
not satisfied with the
the
concurrency and asynchronous
features from your language. I I definitely
recommend to check out
z o z I o library
on top of Scala. Awesome. Thank you.
Alright. Well, thank you so much for spending
time with me today answering all these questions,
sharing all of your knowledge and all the
interest and problems that you have in Wix
engineering,
and most importantly, how you're navigating and solving
them.
I'd like to give you just a moment.
Feel free to share and shamelessly plug, Wix,
yourself, your blog, your Twitter, your, if you
have a daily farm, like, anything you wish,
please feel free to share. Well, first of
all, it was really a pleasure, being on
the show, and,
you're a great host. And I really enjoyed
your questions,
kept kept me, on my toes.
And a lot of things I talked about
today
are
on my website, so at natansill.com.
Block posts on on ranging from,
like, event driven architecture
and
more like Kafka specific. I talked about skill
management.
And
but I also have other software engineering in
broader terms related stuff there.
And
you can and also, I do a lot
of talks and a lot of conferences, so
you could check out all that in my
on at my website as well. And, yeah,
you can find me on Twitter and LinkedIn
for sure where I I I get updates
on everything that we do at Wix Engineering,
which is interesting.
So that's it. Alright.
Well, thank you again. I will ensure that
all of those links are in the show
notes for people to check out. So to
everyone listening, thank you very much, and we'll
see you all next time. Have a great
day.